bonsoir tout le quart à merci d'être
avec nous la coalition citoyenne pour le
sel qui a émis un certain nombre de
recommandations axées sur les besoins
des populations il est encore le temps
de changer de stratégie il avantage pour
ces données sont non gouvernementales
elles sont au contact régulier par maman
sont en contact permanent avec les
populations
donc les attentes et celles ci sont
clairement entendu parce zone du ch et
d'un décès fait effectivement le sprint
aux jo les maliens fois aux attaques
terroristes les nigériens le burkinabè
on pourra vous attaquez vous pourrez
découvrir naturellement ces populations
bout du compte qu'effectivement les
réponses méditation cirque nécessaires
mais elles permettent pas à elles seules
de continuer tout une paix durable d'où
effectivement à cette nécessité et des
refontes d'édition de réponse militaire
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont opposés par les
seigneurs et par les partenaires à nos
clients de la société française alors
comment se fait-il selon vous que que
malgré la présence accrue des militaires
de l'opération barkan les menaces contre
les civils aient n'est finalement jamais
cessé d'augmenter alors qu'on ne sont
quand même plus ses forces partenaires
et les forces nationales allant plus une
fonction vitale à dans cette ligue
contre le gouffre et les coups violents
même si le coma doit s'inscrit dans la
bulle et en dépit de cette présence
combinée des forces nationales et
internationales les populations
effectivement ont le sentiment d'être le
plus en plus éloigné de cette paix tant
recherchée par sa population et donc
vous dire qu'effectivement l'édifiante
et je pense qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
proposés elle met le focus est de mettre
l'accent sur le tout militaire or la
sécurité dans ces différents endroits où
il y est question d'organisation sociale
qu'elles sont la gouvernance
si vous regardez aujourd'hui les 4 500
certes on a une exigence mais lesquels
action logement
gourmet pas relax défense sécurité donc
les 40 majorité des réponses proposées
par l'organe de 500 sont des réponses
malheureusement militaire or les
problèmes surgis le plan culturel le
problème il est même entre produit donc
de ce fait les populations et les
animations de submersibles vers
davantage que l élite militaire saigne
end que les huit militaires occidentales
notamment françaises et coûtent de plus
en plus écrit de coeur les populations
sur le jour dit que les assume
pleinement effectivement dans
l'élaboration défense statique
concernant jusqu'ici malheureusement si
vous le gagnez du sommet de pau au
récent sommet n'a auquel ce sommet n'a
associé des acteurs qui sont les
populations de ces endroits on pourra
aux attaques terroristes
la coalition citoyenne préconise le
dialogue avec les djihadistes
est ce que c'est possible pour vous la
possibilité cette nécessité absolue
vous ne pouvez pas combattre avec quelle
efficacité pertinence des actes epsp at
on une référence idéologique d actrice
et patty on a des référents religieux
pas de simples un poste canon à deux
simple réponse militaire le 17 il est
extrêmement important aujourd'hui que
cette offre il ya look six ans elle ne
te couperai les coups violents et
derrière laquelle offre n a été qu avant
il faut le rappeler
proposé par les maliens lors de la
conférence en novembre 2007 de la nation
et qu'ils y fin 2019 même également
récemment burkina je viens de quitter le
boucler à peine après trois jours où les
populations dans les vingt quatre mois
j'ai buté sur le thème que s'il ya ne
soit déclenchée ainsi vous pourrez
découvrir les réponses militaires ou les
reconnaissances elles sont nécessaires
mais elles ne peuvent aucunement
combattre cette idée mais j'étais aux
listes l'impôt sunnite à elle seule ne
peut pas permettre de comprendre
davantage tous et deviennent compliquées
liés à la gestion du fonds c'est toute
cette mamie confusion liée à la pyramide
sociale laquelle ce stade
malheureusement amis
certaines catégories de population si la
touche parce qu elles sont toutes ces
catégories des tesla ou descendante un
véritable conte comment allez vous
arrivez avec le considérable dans un
conflit qui ôte en multi mais pas de
détention compte qu'ils ont pour moi les
français à des tensions que l'on peut
m'en excuse la géométrie variable sans
pourtant associé effectivement est
pleinement
c'est une population aujourd'hui qu'ils
veulent dans le module merci à lee tout
cas d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
que vous êtes directeur du centre des
études sécuritaires et stratégiques au
sel